first we need to ask you to ensure that
if you or anyone in your household has
one of those two symptoms then you
should stay at home for 14 days that
means that if possible you should not go
out even to buy food or essentials other
than for exercise and in that case at a
safe distance from others if necessary
you should ask for help from others for
your daily necessities and if that is
not possible then you should do what you
can to limit your social contact when
you leave the house to get supplies and
even if you don't have symptoms and if
no one in your household has symptoms
there is more that we need you to do now
so second now is the time for everyone
to stop non-essential contact with
others and to stop all unnecessary
travel we need people to start working
from home where they possibly can and
you should avoid pubs clubs theaters and
other such social venues it goes without
saying repeat the message we should all
only use the NHS when we really need to
and please go online rather than ringing
NHS one one one